we have this story Elliot Page Reveals
chilling transphobic attack outside La
Hotel
quote I'm going to effing gay bashu and
then homophobic slur and then the guy
apparently uh in the most prominent gay
neighborhood probably in the country of
which is West Hollywood in Los Angeles
well maybe it's maybe San Francisco
District yeah but but La West Hollywood
is one of the most prominent gay
neighborhoods in the country this is
where Elliot page was and then after
this person said this followed Elliot
page into a store called Pink Dot and
then said this is why I need a gun it's
amazing I can't believe it this story
coming out on the same day that Elliot
page has released their new book
so uh nobody believes the story I mean
come on so a guy was walking around Los
Angeles in in literally The Boys Town of
Los Angeles and was shocked and outraged
to see someone who he assumed was gay
specifically said gay bash and then this
is why I need a gun like it it best fan
fiction it's bad fan fiction for
liberals guns are bad see that's why
they want guns who who is that I don't
know who that is Elliott page yeah
formerly Ellen Page
have you ever seen Juno
yeah that that was uh the girl from Juno
yeah yeah yeah and she transitioned to
oh that's so Elliott about yeah and then
there's a there's a big question about
whether or not Elliot page has fake
implants for the
yeah that's gotta be fair a lot because
a lot of people are saying like if you
look at Ellie Page's arms it doesn't
when you when you work out your your
core for abs there's a uh whenever you
work on a muscle there's like a 30
transference to the surrounding muscles
because all muscles are working it's not
just like when you're like working out
your arms you're actually using a bunch
of other muscles too so you would have
muscle development on other areas so a
lot of people are like Elliott page got
implants to look like a dude with abs or
whatever I just think this person's a
liar well this story I think I think
they they're suffering from severe
depression I think that was publicly
known and I think that results in
Desperate cries for attention like the
most ridiculous story you've ever heard
I'm sorry it's I don't know what's more
ridiculous jussie Smollett or this to be
fair it is possible this happened the
justiceable that thing is kind of like
yo get out of here that's even worse
yeah Chicago 2 A.M Sub-Zero weather two
guys carrying bleach and a string from a
hardware store this is maybe there was a
crazy home this guy muttering and
sputtering and rambling and then SAR you
know but he did not use that for next he
did not say I am going to gay bash you
like that's not that's not how people
talk that's not a thing anybody's like
no if if Elliot page claimed the guy
said oh I'm going you disgust me I'm
gonna get you or something I'd be like
okay that makes more sense this kind of
reminds me what we're just talking about
how we only get potentially half the
story what led up to this interaction
was Elliot screaming at the guy because
if she's a miserable depressed person I
wouldn't put it past well him I wouldn't
put it past him to to wail on someone
verbally okay maybe
um there was a unicorn that was flying
to the sky and it pooped and the poop
landed on this gigantic Behemoth of an
angry man who then turned and saw Elliot
page picking flowers for Elliot's mother
and then went oh boy I'm so angry oh boy
it was Dash because if we're just gonna
make things up I'll make up whatever I
want if she's gonna make something up
I'll just make up how it started there
you go there's the story what do you
think Pearl well I have a I have a
question how know if I can say this or
not oh I don't write it on a piece of
paper
[Music]
yeah
don't brag I just have a question but I
don't know if this question will okay oh
she's writing a race too hot for TV I I
don't know I can't believe you oh my
gosh wait wait wait you said this wait
Sheamus is sweating I'm like this is
this is a close-up on Sheamus's eyeballs
I feel like it's gonna be a very
innocuous question I don't think it's
that bad but I just don't want to I
don't I just hear guys
what I basically said was oh so I I I I
will check with Tim but I'm pretty sure
yes I'll just ask him one of these
things for those that are wondering what
we're talking about basically what we
tell people is I don't know if you can
but it's true I don't know if you can
say that but it's yeah I'm pretty sure
you can say it you you're not so on
YouTube you do not insult someone based
on their immutable characteristics okay
outside of that you're fine what about
questioning their mental stability is
that okay I'm pretty sure that Elliot
Pages publicly expressed they have
mental illness oh okay so why are we
taking like the word seriously of
someone that's mentally ill like why are
they getting articles and stuff I think
I think Ellie page has specifically
talked about severe depression and
anxiety and disorders and things like
that I could be wrong it could be wrong
but um but I was more I was more
interesting because of the other you
know stuff but it's not it's not about
being mentally ill it's about selling a
book right like this story comes out the
same day the book is getting released
this is not this is not mental illness
this is this is cold calculating
marketing wow
I think it's just crazy it's it's
marketing just why did Jesse Smith do it
because he was renegotiating his
contract on Empire and he wanted to be a
hot ticket item and why now is this
story come out June 6 is the release
date for page boy the new book what a
weird marketing strategy right the the
new like fake hate crime marketing firm
out there that's telling these people
that this will help their Public Image
but it makes sense right because we live
in a victimhood culture if you want
people to sympathize with you you have
to be a victim because that would make
That's What Makes You impressive yeah
I'm real Fed Up on the victimhood
culture it's getting under my skin
just now
no no no totally agree I just wanted to
do you get that do you constantly
interact with victims on the on your
show oh my
I just think women nowadays just want to
be victim it's like everything like I
have never heard a girl come on a show
because we talk about relationships a
lot and just so you know what that
relationship was my fault yeah I've
never heard a girl say that oh there was
a story today uh I was reading in the
Daily Mail and it was a woman crying
because her fiance left her and said it
was my fault because I wouldn't listen
to why he was upset and I was too
stubborn to compromise and now he's gone
yeah and it made news headlines
if you ask a guy like he had a nice girl
he maybe cheated on her he'll kind of
admit it he'll be like you know what
yeah I was a dog I was this but it's
like girls just find the craziest ways
to make themselves the victim in every
relationship gosh that's hilarious in
every religion gosh and I used to not
really understand like why guys were
complaining about dating so much I was
like why are the guys complaining like
why are they saying this is so bad and
then I started doing the show and I was
like oh my gosh it's worse than I
thought it's like one the girls are so
flaky coming on the show I've never been
really flaked on by guys women it's like
50 I literally have to book it really 50
50. if they'll show up I booked double
the amount of women because I know half
will cancel are they probably are they
no are you being hyperbolic or is it
really half half I mean I don't I
haven't recruited in a while but when I
did the recruiting myself yeah I and we
book uh 10 girls for the show we don't
give our recruiters 10 slots and so like
the that's like the most mics we have we
expect like half to come it's for one
show you'll have ten invites yeah 10
invites
um I mean sometimes we add in guys too
so like they're guys it depends on the
show but yeah that's wild so half the
time they just don't show up do you
think though is is it something about
like your show being more controversial
that makes them feel more frightened to
do no this was even before I was bit
like this was like I like I started at
15 that was at 15 000 Subs a year ago
well people think it was the show but it
actually wasn't the show well sort of I
would do a show right and we would talk
about like
I don't know maybe the pay Gap not being
real or like not not the way they think
right like basic like kind of red pill
truths right and I would see a girl
where like the wheels were sort of
turning where she was kind of
understanding what I was saying when I
would say like you know the reason for
the pay Gap is because we don't work as
many hours we don't do as dangerous job
like you know et cetera we flake on
podcasts that kind of thing yeah yeah
and so what I would do is I would invite
the girls back and I would show them
like um a red pilling like video so one
of the First videos that went viral was
I read pulled my friend for the first
time and it was like um a 45 minute
video of Jordan Peterson arguing with
that feminist on the pay Gap right and
so but these would be like these would
be like three hour conversations really
in-depth like just like where I'm like
slowly sort of like deconstructing what
they believe and you know because at one
point like I mean I thought the pickup
was real like I mean not not any time
recently but yeah you're even when
you're younger right and so that's what
initially blew it up was like it would
be like red pilling women in real time I
found it that's what I found it but the
story is real but also um Don King on
women does well too woman left by her
fiance burst into tears as she confesses
the one mistake she made and she
basically says that they would get into
fights yeah I was too good for a failure
to address the problems caused them to
escalate and ultimately neither was
willing to make sacrifices or compromise
on their stance after the relationship
ended cam realize that she should have
been less stubborn and tried to
appreciate her partner's Viewpoint and
now she's now she's alone dang and it
made news headlines yeah why I mean I
guess that's a big deal for modeling it
was like woman admits fault yeah it's a
it's a sad story it happens
um I think that uh part of what this
culture does is it creates this Warfare
between men and women and of course the
man is always the bad guy everything's
his fault and you see this repeatedly
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time